so in the newspapers apparently this
week the Russians are responsible for
brexit apparently the Russians are
responsible for I'm sorry if we were
responsible for brexit bricks it would
be done yeah we'd be out we were taking
chakra France with us only three years
of negotiations one meeting done
imagine that Russian delegation goes
over to France like undermine everybody
so president
don't ask called white card okay we're
supposed to live on October 31st or
January 31st now we're not yesterday
that's how much we don't like you also
we have this sub problem with Irish
portal is very complicated up explain to
me what is the borders
don't hear this uh before I go I should
explain we had a little bit to how you
say a revolution in People's Republic of
Britain yes yes we will move to resume
so now we have Prime Minister good
Russian name and label either with
Russian policies actually we're rested
comrade karden but that guy is tough
yeah we interrogate him for a week still
don't know dispositional break CDs I
wrote that joke
two years ago gets better every day